also tonight crime in major
democratic-run cities like New York
continues to spiral way out of control
while Democratic leaders like failing
far left New York Governor Kathy hokel
continues to coddle these violent
criminals devastating consequences
remember billion dollars in cuts to the
NYPD no bail laws all over New York you
might recall yesterday we showed you
this video of a man going on an ax
Rampage inside of McDonald's and the
suspect was promptly released on bail a
guy swinging an ax in McDonald's like
that and by the way he's back on the
street remember the case of Jose Alba
over the summer who was charged for
defending his Bodega when the guy came
around the counter and attacked him and
by the way in a violent encounter ensued
and then the D.A charged the victim in
this particular case that had the every
right to defend himself but anyway we
have these far too often we see these
far left leaders turning villains into
victims victims into villains and it is
now causing a collapse inside our major
cities now in New York Lee zeldin is
vowing to protect victims and refund the
police reduce crime increase the quality
of life for working Americans across the
state of New York are Americans fed up
with all the crime are New Yorkers fed
up with all the crime what's interesting
is opponent Governor Kathy hokel who
took over for Andrew Cuomo doesn't even
want to debate like most democratic
candidates this election cycle and a
poll released earlier this month shows
Lee Zelda now within the margin of error
in deep blue New York here with reaction
New York Republican gubernatorial
candidate Lee zeldon first the crime is
that bad it is out of control they're
releasing people that are committing
violent crimes we see it again and again
we can show a lot of tape if people want
why is it the governor has steadfastly
refused to rescind these no bail laws
why is it that they're not refund
funding the NYPD instead of defunding it
she's weak in pandering to far left
pro-criminal allies in her own party
when I was calling for a repeal of
cashless Bell she was saying that there
wasn't any data to support it
essentially her position is that you
have to elect her to find out what her
position on changing Castle's bail might
be in January when I was pledging to
fire Alvin Bragg as soon as I get sworn
into office he said he just got there
cut up some slack he's doing his job you
mentioned the Jose Alba case I was
standing in front of Bragg's office
calling on the murder charges to get
dropped and when she was asked about it
that same day she says it's a local
matter she's not going to get involved
you know meanwhile when she was making
this move after the Supreme Court
overturned New York's unconstitutional
concealed carry law she was asked just a
couple days before her new law passed
well what day did you have to Target
concealed carry permit holders and she
says she doesn't need data she's the
governor and everyone woke up in the
state legislature that Friday morning
and there was no bill by that afternoon
there was a Bill signing so she's been
all wrong on crime and I believe that
New Yorkers of all walks of life you
don't have to be a republican everybody
wants Safe Streets here's the if there's
one problem I see that you have it's
that so many people have left the state
of New York because of crime uh quality
of life issues high taxes burdensome
regulation that might have otherwise
been very willing to vote for a
republican so demographically it's tough
especially in New York City but yet
you're within the margin of error is it
possible for a republican to win the
governorship in New York
so I'm not in this race to come in
second you know the stakes there are a
lot of New Yorkers hitting their
Breaking Point New York leads the entire
nation in population loss because people
have their wallet their safety their
freedom the quality of their kids
education under attack and they know
that if they go elsewhere that their
money will go further they'll feel safer
they'll live life Freer so I believe
that there are New Yorkers of all walks
of life and we've seen it from people
who might have always voted Democrat in
their lives we see what the Hispanic
vote has now changed from November 2020
to now and others they're ready to come
our way but we have to work for it
taking nothing for granted all in well
the rest of the state in the last
election went pretty red the only part
that is really blue is New York City
we'll see what happens but you're
definitely in the fight and we really
are going to watch this closely Lee
zeldon thanks for being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else